redonner à la classe moyenne l'espoir en
un avenir meilleur
voilà notre plan la campagne électorale
sera bientôt lancée au canada on vous
propose ce soir un bilan économique du
gouvernement trudeau avec geneviève
tellier professeur à l'école d'études
politiques de l'université d'ottawa et
l'économiste daniel denis madame
monsieur bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
alors on entendait monsieur trudeau
c'était lors de la campagne électorale
de 2015 redonner de l'espoir la classe
moyenne les mots que là le mot classe
moyenne les mots classes moyennes sont
revenus à plusieurs reprises au coeur du
discours des libéraux dès le départ
madame tandis que le gouvernement
trudeau a rempli ses promesses envers la
classe moyenne
oui pour la classe moyenne vous voyez je
suis assez catégorique là mais il y
avait une promesse phare dans sa plate
forme qui était la location canadienne
pour enfants destinés à la classe
moyenne
une classe moyenne la définition est
très large aussi alors tout canadien qui
gagnait en tout familles qui gagnent
entre 26 mai les 150 mille dollars par
année à peu près et teligent et pas
cette allocation là pour tout le temps
le même montant ce qui veut dire à peu
près plus de 90 % des contribuables
canadiens et c'était une promesse qui a
été faite à peine deux mois après
l'élection du gouvernement ils ne
m'aiment pas attendu le dépôt de son
premier budget pour adopter le projet de
loi qui met en place la location
monsieur denis vous en pensez quoi vous
mais je te fais d'accord sauf que je
sais que j'étais peut-être pas au vin
peut peut-être le plan économique du
gouvernement en 2015 dans le sens que
c'est se limitait beaucoup le font ainsi
d'augmenter la consommation de la classe
moyenne c'est sûr que les faits étaient
positifs parce que un dollar qui est
donné de plus une famille de deux
classes moyennes la proportion qui est
dépensé puis à dépenser au canada est
plus grande que 1 $ par exemple en plus
d'en mieux nantis ou aux plus riches par
ailleurs c'est à dire que la fois
l'optique du gouvernement libéral
d'époque dans le cadre de son programme
puis aussi leadership dans les cinq
derniers de son gouvernement étaient
présents de stimuler la consommation et
moins de travailler sur l'appareil
productif canadien parce qu on a baissé
les impôts aussi pour la nouvelle
liaison augmenter les impôts des mieux
nantis cependant
et oui exactement pour compenser une
partie due à l'effet des enfants des
baisses au niveau de la classe moyenne
de madame tellier vous allez ajouter
quelque chose oui mais il ya eu un
changement majeur c'est à dire qu'on a
fait une redistribution de l'impôt
c'est-à-dire que lorsque les libéraux
étaient au pouvoir auparavant à voir les
conservateurs on parlait de baisses
d'impôt généralisée à tout le monde les
riches les pauvres la classe moyenne
c'est pour la première fois depuis je
voudrais qu'ils en veuillent temps où le
parti libéral dit on va faire une
redistribution du fardeau fiscal est
donc je pense que justin trudeau dizaine
en ces mots on va demander aux mieux
nantis canadiens de faire un peu plus
leur part pour financer des services
publics pour la majorité de la
population
c'est vraiment être un changement
discours majeur qu'on a vu sur la scène
fédérale
même politique canadienne des dernières
années sur le plan budgétaire déficit de
20 milliards cette année
presque 70 milliards de déficit si on
les additionne les quatre années alors
que cette année monsieur denis ça devait
être le retour l équilibre budgétaire
est ce qu est ce qu on doit se
préoccuper de cela
dans ce cas ci c'est sûr que c'est une
promesse qui était non remplies par
contre les faits l'effet est moins
dommageable qu'on pourrait anticiper ou
tout au moins qu'on aurait pu le dire il
ya peut-être dix ans où il ya quinze ans
d'une part fauvarque l'endettement
canadiens restent limités surtout quand
on comprend dans le fond aux autres
grands pays le déficit budgétaire aussi
en proportion du pib canadien reste très
faible et on a un contexte actuellement
qui fait en sorte que y'a pas beaucoup
d'effets négatifs n'y a pas d'effets
négatifs aux déficits gouvernementaux du
gouvernement canadien
parce que dans le fond si on regarde les
impacts négatifs peuvent venir d'une
baisse de confiance des entrepreneurs ou
une baisse de confiance des
consommateurs à cause de cette dette
l'on se préoccupe pas ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre tellement des déficits canadien
et on peut aussi avoir des fois ce qu'on
appelle de l'éviction c'est à dire qu'on
déplace on va chercher tellement
d'argent sur les marchés qu'on déplace
le secteur privé que plus de difficultés
dans le fond lui a emprunté et c'est pas
le cas parce que le secteur privé
n'investit pas suffisamment
d'une certaine façon ce qui fait qu'ils
aient pas beaucoup d'effets négatifs il
ya un risque de banaliser
potentiellement à terme les déficits
mais pour l'instant ça a eu un impact
positif sur le plan économique jusqu'à
quel point ma dans ce livre faire
entendre ou sur ce midi
forme de commerce du montréal
métropolitain les conservateurs aussi
ont changé leur discours sur le
difficile la chambre souhaite une
clôture à l'équilibré budgétaire d'ici
les quatre prochaines années et je
comprends tout à fait votre impatience
mais à cause de la négligence camp de
luz du présent gouvernement
il faudra peut-être une année de plus
pour revenir à l'équilibré mais je veux
je vous assure que nous allons y mettre
à la tâche immédiatement après notre
réaction est que nous répondrons
rapidement le contrôle de nos finances
alors les libéraux ne donne pas de
retour de déficit zéro les conservateurs
disent dans cinq ans madame changements
forts la charge rap c'est là que les
libéraux ont gagné parce
qu'effectivement c'était le temps de
faire des déficits je suis d'accord pour
dire que c'est pas dommage alors ce
moment la situation déficitaire au
canada onf l envi de la plupart des pays
dos et des oeufs et donc même les partis
le parti conservateur ne veut pas
retourner à l'équilibré budgétaire à
l'intérieur d'un an ou deux comme on
pensait que ça se produirait il ya
quelques temps je re même prenez
l'alberta avec jason kenney qui lui même
le premier poids un retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire rapidement donc il ya
vraiment eu un changement de mentalité à
travers le canada
probablement à cause de l'exemple
libéral fédéral mais je suis d'accord
pour dire faudrait faire attention parce
que si on en crée une habitude
éventuellement ça pourrait gonfler et
lol le coup d'avoir des déficits
pourrait augmenter dans son van
récession en tout cas des groupes plus
grands accords commerciaux partenariat
transpacifique accord avec l'union
européenne l'alena finalement un nouvel
à l'ena de peine et de misère est ce que
le premier ministre une bonne note là
dessus données les données ou et moi je
dirais que par ses permis par amal et
les meilleures réalisations du
gouvernement trudeau en matière
économique
pas nécessairement parce que l'on sait
dans le fond les trois dans l'es3
négociations que ce soit trans pacifique
avec l'europe ou avec est due dans le
fond c'est des processus qui était en
cause c'est pour sa peau était initié
mais c'est lyon démontré une fermeté au
niveau de d'avoir une ouverture le plus
possible la meilleure possible aussi
pour le canada où le monde
on a perdu des choses au change mais
c'est normal dans les négociations et je
pense que ça démontre notamment les
difficultés qu'ont avec les états unis
notamment ce qui se passe actuellement
avec la chine que le canada pour le
choix il est trop petit il doit
travailler sur des accords commerciaux
et doit travailler sur des accords
commerciaux multi pays parce que sinon
ils risquent d'être tout simplement
tassée au détriment de l'économie
canadien de l'atelier oui effectivement
je pense qu'on a été frappé par la
réalité
puis bon c'était pas une promesse
électorale l'alena parce que j'avais pas
donald trump à l'époque donc est arrivé
le phénomène tromper qu'est ce qu'on
fait et ça a été extrêmement dommageable
de ne pas avoir de traiter libre échange
parce qu'on aurait eu une attente une
pause économique c'est à dire aucun
investissement ou en fait très peu
d'investissements parce que les
entreprises auraient été dans la tente
de qu'est ce qui arrive ça nous prend un
accord ça nous en prend un rapidement
donc c'est aussi la rapidité avec
laquelle l'accord a été signé
ça a été un très bon coup de monsieur
trudeau et je peu convaincus qu'un autre
gouvernement aurait fait mieux vis-à-vis
le personnage de monsieur trompe quand
je sais à mettre dans le bilan positif
du gouvernement trudeau amont dans le
bilan négatif est ce qu'on mettrait la
taxe carbone et 30 mountain dans le même
panier parce qu'on al'impression madame
tellier que tout le monde est déçu que
le gouvernement a fait des mécontents
des deux côtés franz wenzel oui c'est
une décision qui a mécontenté tout le
monde alors en matière d'environnement
je pense que la plupart des pas des
partis à celle de plaire à certains
suffisamment pour avoir une bonne base
mais savent qu'on peut pas plaire à tout
le monde mais dans ce que si on ne dit
plus à tout le monde alors ceux qui
veulent qu'on développe l'industrie
pétrolière dans l'ouest veut ça va pas
assez vite et le projet est un peu
arrêter le fait du surplace ceux qui ne
veulent pas qu'on investisse dans
l'industrie pétrolière ballon on a un
pipeline est alors que la promesse
électorale avait été de dire dont ne
subventionne plus l'industrie pétrolière
donc ça déplaît à tout le monde pour la
taxe carbone je suis un peu moins
ambivalente c'est à dire que
je pense que la plupart des canadiens on
ne vise des résultats de sondages ce
matin la plupart des canadiens semblent
appuyer l'idée d'une taxe carbone mais
là on depuis de province avec lequel
travailler pour faire justement 7,7
d'accueil a beaucoup de contestations
c'est exact monsieur denis ouais je
pense que la taxe carbone
d'un point de vue d'économies je pense
est une chose qui est importante qui
doit être soutenu ça a été mal vendu
pomme et c'est en partie je pense avec
toute la notion justement ça a été
annoncé une taxe
puis on le voit le vu avec la fois le
dossier netflix zec les libertins mal à
l'aise aussi de parler de taxe et la
fois l'opposition en a profité pour
dresser une nouvelle taxe sur les
individus alors que dans le fond c'est
c'est quelque chose qui dit allemands
souhaitaient entendre pour changer des
comportements qui est dans le foie il ya
des coups qui sont à sociale soit qu'ils
sont pas sont pas assumés par sa paire
certains joueurs mais le dossier
l'énergie je pense que fondamentalement
ça monte un peu la difficulté qu'a eue
le grand trudeau a apporté des fonds
d'une réflexion peut-être proactive sur
certaines industries
on était très très réactif l'énergie à
un exemple on est arrivé avec acheteurs
de dire des ducs
on va dire dans la forêt on était aussi
très réactif mais dans l'aéronautique
qui est arrivé la cseries
c'est comme si on a on veut travailler à
augmenter la consommation le fait par
les déficits budgétaires le fait par les
baisses d'impôts à castans moyenne mais
au niveau de ce qu'est ce qu'on va mener
le canada sur le plan du développement
comme et condamné canal sous
développement industriel sont n'avait
pas de position et puis on a comme réagi
puis ça le démontre un peu cette
incohérence offs et improvisation là
dans le dossier énergétique
un mot un mot monsieur denis meilleure
réalisation
j'irai compétences et 20,2 la politique
d'immigration même si c'est pas le cas
de l'objectif actuellement mais c'est
important compte tenu des pénuries au
québec qu'ailleurs et sa compagne plus
récemment de du dossier de la formation
des compétences de notation des
compétences dans le dernier budget s'est
pas vraiment quelque chose qui n'est pas
très gros sur le le radar mais qui est
extrêmement important compte tenu des
enjeux économiques à nos ateliers
moi je vais aller y avait quelque chose
qui est gros alors la location
canadienne pour enfants
pourquoi je la choisis parce que stocker
de l'heure
dans leur vision économique comme me
suis donné le bien dit on vit sur la
consommation de la population pour
relancer l'économie il fallait le faire
il fallait faire tout de suite même si
les ressources budgétaires étaient moins
que prévu et on l'a fait
j'aimerais vous retrouver en campagne
électorale vous est passionnant janvier
atelier daniel denis merci beaucoup aux
plaisirs merci